could this be the camera system
that pulls you away from full frame
and brings you into a psc let's find out
[Music]
what's up guys i'm bobby and we are back
talking about the all-new fujifilm
xh2s just been announced but we've had
our hands on this camera twice once in
april and once in the middle of may as
we're recording this video right now now
during both of these times these have
been pre-production firmware i mean i
could say the body is pretty much final
but the firmware has been buggy issues
air issues sometimes focusing but
the performance has been absolutely
spectacular for what we've experienced
thus far now we're partnering up with
ivan josh willow who is a fujifilm
ambassador here in singapore we've done
videos with them in the past and with
the great support from fujifilm
singapore as well we have all the
accessories we have the new lenses we're
going to take the camera through its
paces and we're going to do that right
now so let's go back in time to middle
april with ivan and see how this camera
performs with flash with tracking at 40
frames per second let's check it out
[Music]
you know it's great not to have to work
proportions review hang out
let ivan do all the heavy lifting with
the xhs 2s
with rita the beautiful model i'm just
looking over zacky and making sure that
his lens doesn't have dust on it it's a
nice day it's actually a really nice day
zach you look at the view out here look
at this look really nice it's nice we
just need a nice drink up here hang out
hey ivan what are you doing so that's
ivan right there he's trying out the new
150 to 600.
how do you feel with that lens ivan
you feel invincible yeah
size matters i was going to hang out
today zac
how are you feeling right now zach zack
you really got in shape man you really
lost a lot of weight man been at the gym
take a look wow look at that wait a
second this is interesting what it's
picking up you're at 150 only yeah
what away man it's picking up the faces
of joe and
it's picking up the eye tracking from
here
wait a second you can't even see the eye
through the evf there's no the faces are
black and it's picking up the eye i'm
just gonna put it out there man this is
very close to sony
very close to sony very close to what we
see from sony and canon right now
we're getting this in the xh2s which
changes the landscape entirely now for
fujifilm users out there they're in
sports photography wildlife photography
or even flash photography what you're
doing right here this is
awesome i mean here's the one thing
though that i wish with this camera
system right
is that it was more than 26 megapixels
for this xh2s i wish it was at least 32.
you know because i feel like we've been
that 2426 range for fujifilm for a
number of years already with the xt4 the
xh1
you know all the other aps-c camera
systems but this is a bsi sensor right
it is so that's something new better low
light performance we're seeing the
better auto focusing in this of course
updated uh internals on this processor
all that great stuff
so it
does i mean there's some benefits to
this and then the question is do you
need more than 26 megapixels i don't
rita fly the dress
hey joe you don't have to fly anymore
just pose just ask her to pose yeah i
got it i'm good right see i'm very good
at this glad i could help out the
american comes in and just becomes very
loud obviously we'd use a monopod for
the win for this but the fact that the
ois and the lens and then paired with
the ibis inside of the
xh2 it's good it's in the shadow yeah i
know and it's locked on the face right
yeah it's amazing huh it's really good
600
wow
give me a credit card again okay
question ivan yeah putting on the spot
here you're a gfx user yeah medium
format yep
where do you see the xh2s coming into
your camera bag
as a commercial photographer
yes
um maybe i'll wait for the 40 megapixel
actually really yeah yeah i think the
extra is important to me yeah um low
light is not my kind of thing because
commercially everything's in control
right so um
the megapixel is more important to me
gotcha yeah the extra 14 megapixel okay
means a lot to me right yeah yeah but
will we get that same autofocusing
system i'm very happy i mean but we get
that in the the 40 megapixels right
because we don't know that yet right no
i don't so that's the thing so here's
the question i'm gonna put this to you
hypothetically the 40 megapixel just
more megapixels but you don't get that
great auto focusing system that you're
getting out of this okay which would you
choose 26 26 right yeah i can use that
for sports right
um any fast moving things right i think
sometimes versatility so then you use
100 s for your portrait shots your
commercial work right sports anything
fast action yeah
yeah this would be like a running school
across the street yeah why not it
happens yeah it comes across sometimes
yeah here we go my life is complete but
if the 40 megapixel has the auto
focusing system i'll go for the 40. i'll
go for it gotta go hopefully it's not
more expensive though
i don't know do you know no
it shouldn't be right what shouldn't be
right should be able the same fuji would
would you charge more for the 40
megapixel i don't know if it's not as
fast as the s though
because the s stands for speed i'm
guessing right i don't know something is
sexy it is a sexy camera it's a very
sexy camera it's a really sexy camera
this is a very nice built camera it is
small and good but the grip is fantastic
i know the grip yeah the grip is great
we just need the external grip which
we're going to feature later on in this
video yeah the external grip with the
fan exactly all the great stuff okay
all right all right man okay let's go
let's do it
[Music]
okay we're now at sentosa beach as you
can see i'm in my beach where ivan is as
well and we're going to test uh the 40
frames per second with rita running here
we've got the 150 to 600 with the 1.4
tele converter on this so essentially
we're around
max if you're comparing it to let's say
a full frame focal length around 11 to
1200 millimeters at its uh longest focus
distance on this so it'll be about f11
when we uh converted the teleconverter
on this as well
now right now because this is a
pre-production camera one of the
features that uh we're seeing happen and
or let's say featured but one of the
incidences we're seeing happen is
actually the buffering
isn't really as optimal as it should be
yet
uh this one i'm guessing will be fixed
when the final release comes again we're
shooting this april 12th the camera will
be announced on may 31st so there's
gonna be a lot of firmware updates
between them but you can get some brew
shots out of there right we just got
updated today actually yeah we did get
an update today yeah um it's improved it
from what i tested yesterday but still
there is some buffering happening on
this uh we're using a uhs2 card as well
as a safe express type b card
but i got to tell you
beautiful backlight she looks absolutely
stunning in this the eye tracking even
with the teleconverter is still spot on
so if you guys are worried about that
especially if you're in a birding or
wildlife photography or just want to
shoot models as we're doing here at the
beach at 1200 millimeters you know
essentially with the full frame focal
length on that exactly i'm enjoying it
the af is good it locks in let's find
some concern at this point but we need
to test it out a bit more yeah yeah but
i would prefer the grip though yeah yeah
so i think that's what we're going to do
next so what we're going to do is
because we've had the camera so far in
advance i'm thinking what we'll do is
we'll kind of regroup a few weeks or a
week or two before
the launch we'll test out the video a
little bit more for you guys out there
4k 120 6k
see what's uh what else that fujifilm
puts in with the firmware updates yeah
with the the battery grip yep and the
fan they'll be interesting the fan
attachment to that as well as the
wireless transmitter back here actually
which is cool yeah that's the person
we've ever seen on a camera like this
you actually can't put a fan to the back
of this yeah i think it's charged via
this little slot here which is uh people
always say they wanted their cameras
cooler fujifilm said well we'll just
give you a fan
so uh there you go we'll test it out so
with that guys
we'll check back with you in a few weeks
time which right now will be
in about
now
[Laughter]
as you saw the images of rita were
absolutely beautiful the teleconverter
with the all-new 150 to 600 is fantastic
even the 150 the 600 without the
teleconverter is very sharp high
performing lens yes a little slower in
the aperture but still really good now
what we're going to do is we're going to
take it through its video paces because
of course fujifilm is touting 6k video
of course it's a 3x2 format 6k to 30.
you have pro res hq 422 inside of this
10 bit 422 as well so you're really
getting some high quality video specs in
this along with a great new auto
focusing algorithm in this as well we've
got a cooling fan on the back of this
camera which allows you to record up to
one hour continuously so if you're
worried about overheating fujifilm has
already thought about that we're going
to run it through its paces the all-new
18 to 120 f4 power zoom lens which is
designed for video as well so zacky
let's have some fun let's test some
video
[Music]
here at geek culture we love our
keyboards especially with the all new
logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com hey guys zaki here hope
you loved that segment it was a lot of
fun with the fuji xh2s and i'm gonna
break down the scene here and give my
thoughts on the video capabilities of
the camera so we had the fuji xh2s on
the dji rs2 gimbal with the power zoom
lens and that was basically it no nd
filters nothing and i gotta say i'm
really impressed now looking here i've
isolated this sequence and if we go to
the effect controls here on the top left
you can see that i have not done any
color corrections whatsoever or any
color grading this is straight out of
the camera
all right and the only thing i did was
to add a
2 3 5
crop bars to give a more cinematic feel
that's pretty much
it all right and of course the last shot
was shot with the dji mini 3 pro i
thought it would be nice to you know end
it with such a lovely shot and uh
yeah really loving this drone so far
now i'm really impressed with how this
camera handles exposure and dynamic
range especially when it came to this
segment here
where you see the whites of the car
and bobby's a black shirt i mean it just
handles it so well and even the horizon
with the
cd skyline in the background it just
shows how well the sensor performs and
if we take a look the whites here
the black on bobby's
shirt and even his skin tone is all well
exposed and so it balances out really
well and i can tell like i won't be able
to get the same effect with uh the sony
a7 iii for that matter color wise i was
using the classic chrome filter on the
fuji xh2s i just love the color profile
i think any fuji owner would understand
why
and if you think about it it's
you know you don't need luts anymore
with this so it just saves you time on
the back end to just assemble
your whole sequence and edit it i was a
little bit of a skeptic when it came to
the power zoom lens but once you blow it
up on the bigger screen you can actually
see the sharpness and quality so you can
probably tell that the autofocus
was still iffy at the time of this
recording yeah it does jitter back and
forth a little bit
but
throughout my shoot i think this only
happened about 30 or 40 of the time
but again this is a pre-production
camera so you cannot expect uh the
updates to roll out eventually when it
comes to the autofocus
yeah the cooling fan really helps a lot
uh mind you again this was
40 degrees celsius weather we didn't use
the camera yet we took it out of the
bags the moment we turned it on it was
it was hot it was overheating but once
you add that cooling fan in we were able
to shoot for one hour straight with no
brakes i love this camera so far i think
i'll definitely use this for travel
vlogs and photos and videos so it will
be a great companion for travel
where you don't want to pack a lot of
gear
alrighty that covers the breakdown of
the timeline for the volkswagen tiguan
montage uh hope you enjoyed that one
and let's go back and see bobby and
ivan's final thoughts
so it's been an interesting video ivan i
must say something different for us i
mean because we literally had the camera
two months in advance for the first part
of this video we were shooting in april
with rita which was
that was interesting it is it is jackie
really enjoyed it right now i'm sure he
is yo he enjoyed it yeah yeah he
wouldn't even kind of took a shirt off
during winter exactly yeah yeah voice
portfolio i guess it was it was it was
yeah during that time of course we're
telling that we're testing out the tele
converter with the new 150 to 600
correct that's right and then of course
but this was a beta firmware so
buffering really wasn't that good
autofocusing was good but there was some
error messages coming up on the camera
every now and then and it would kind of
revert back to raw or go to jpeg vice
versa yes now we're may uh what is the
date today jackie
18 18 may 18.
uh about two weeks to launch of this
camera to the announcement of it
firmware has been updated what a bit of
your thoughts thus far with the recent
release of the firmware i love the
improvement after the firmware yeah
autofocus is a lot more accurate faster
precise yeah it's quick not great uh
it's like a like what i told you earlier
it's like a mini beast it is it is i
mean comparing to other cameras reviews
out there
i would say it's very comparable to what
sony's offering in terms of its speed
and consistency i mean again we're still
we're still getting updates from
fujifilm as we go along it's improving
but it is improved greatly do you think
that the xh-2s
will now finally be on the same level as
the hall of fame for all those
high-speed cameras from other
manufacturers
i think we're right there i think we're
in this we're in the same league i
really do and i think this is something
that a lot of fujifilm users have been
waiting for exactly yeah i mean the xt4
did a great job you know what i mean and
the gfx100s well medium format still is
fantastic but this does raise the barb
and you've got they can detect
motorcyclists by the helmet it can
detect cars birds animals that's right
trains trains people all that stuff and
it does a great job with it let's talk
image quality for a second because
you've shot a lot of images and i've
shot some but tell me what you thought
your thoughts on the image quality
um
i don't think there's any vast
improvement on the image quality i think
they're both 26 yeah i think probably
it's a
low light there'll be some improvement
especially to help with the stack sensor
for autofocus sure
other than that i don't think there's a
huge improvement as far as i'm concerned
right i've not really checked between
the old sensor and the current sensor
right but in terms of image quality in
terms of speed
it has improved a lot yeah i mean also a
lot of has to do with the lenses because
we're using the newer lenses which are
designed to resolve more
so effectively 26 can look like a 30
plus megapixel image uh which is
something that i noticed that really
when you use let's say the 33 1.4 this
new 150 to 600 they're fantastic lenses
and even this this new power zoom lens
we're actually reporting on right now i
love it i tried a couple of times with
the new 18 to 120 f4 yeah i love the
carson it's good right you can control
the
speed of the zoom yes and there's a ring
on the lens unlike a switch that other
power zoom manufacturers use we won't
name name sony but um actually it's a
ring yeah so it allows you to control
the speed of it which is much better i
love i enjoy doing that even though i
use it for photography i think it's
quite fun let's just zoom in zoom out
zoom in zoom out exactly yeah video wise
i gotta say i think the video uh quality
is impressive i mean fujifilm has always
done really good on video and i think a
lot of people
you know they always think of the big
three nikon canon sony right you know
for video camera and sony for the most
part but fujifilm
the image quality come out of it is
fantastic it's something that i tested
with the gfx100s the xt4 and the xh2s to
me
i mean you've got pro res options in
this now you got 4k 120 but we're still
getting some errors with the 4k 120. so
we weren't able to really test that out
100 here but you got a cooling fan on
the back of this now to reduce the heat
i know to record for up to one hour
consistently it's very quiet even at
high speed it is i can't even hear it
right now it's on the camera you know
zach is still sweating so it's not
really cool exactly off
but i mean that's something i like hq
talk about it i agree i agree to improve
on it you know the photographer needs to
be cool yeah both sides you know just
the camera and the photographer yeah
but to wrap things up here a bit where
do you think this camera sits do you
think
an aps-c camera 26 megapixels now 40
frames per second 6k uh video 4k 120
the design where do you think this sits
in the camera market i think fuji has
arrived in terms of making the ultimate
camera for a aps-c that's why it's
called the beast to me there's nothing
this camera cannot do true in term of
speed low light
the way it focused the way it locks
whether you're from the burning
community or just as a commercial
photographer you do your hybrid
photographer you do both video and
photography
this will be it i agree it's actually it
is a true hybrid camera which i think is
we're seeing is the new phase into this
is that camera manufacturers who don't
have a cinema line per se
but are really trying to encapsulate
all the video qualities they can of
course you know maintaining heat and yes
you know all that uh you know
performance of it but also with the auto
focusing and i think the xh2s has done a
tremendous job in that if there's any
improvements in this i just wish it was
30 plus megapixels i know there's a 40
megapixel version coming out
but yeah i mean we already know it's
already been announced okay at the time
of this video it's been nice
it would have been nice to see a 30 plus
megapixel just to sort of differentiate
from the 26 that we've been using in the
past number of years
that would be my only issue with this
outside of it the body design is
fantastic the grip is phenomenal
the options for video are there the auto
focusing has improved tremendously i
love the size of it two options for grip
right two options yeah so we have we
have one with wi-fi one without that's
right we have the wi-fi version they
look exactly the same yeah i mean it's
just if you need wi-fi if you don't then
just get the standard grip but um
they've done a great job with that you
put two batteries inside of it plus the
matter inside the camera so i think
fujifilm has made a hell of a camera
here they really have and i'm not we're
not paid well i'm not paid for sponsor i
mean obviously he's an ambassador hence
the shirt but i mean my honest opinion i
was really impressed with this camera i
am too i mean as an ambassador i've
tried many fujifilm cameras but this is
the one that blew me away
in terms of the stability the capability
as a truly hybrid professional camera
all right i love it there you go anyway
that's our first impressions on the xh2s
of course this is all pre-production
firmware so when we do get final
firmware we may revisit the camera in
the near future with that guys follow us
on facebook subscribe to the channel
also ivan what's your instagram and here
what's your website instagram is uh
fujifanboys yup yup and your website
website is pixelandfly.com that's my own
website all right follow him as well
with that guys take care stay safe we'll
chat to you very soon
[Music]
you